hello I'm here to give you the review
the Dark Knight Rises not the review you
deserve but the one you need okay I'm
not gonna do that um okay yeah this is
the most much-anticipated Dark Knight
Rises and I'll just apologize now I'm
doing this before I do the bum review so
if I reuse some of these jokes I
apologize or if you've already seen them
and you see do that whatever uh so okay
as always best way to talk about the
sequel or remake is to talk about we
thought the film's before it just do the
Christopher Nolan ones we do most you
know what I think about but I'll just
say real fast
the Batman Begins I really liked it
really enjoyed it I like the first half
much more than the second half second
half I think it's a little boring but
first half I loved the psychology I love
the philosophy I didn't think I liked
going to his past but I did and I loved
the development so like the first one
second one love even more one of my
favorite movies even though you know it
has problems obviously uh you know the
ending is kind of bullshit and stuff uh
like I really liked it I loved Heath
Ledger I loved that it really seemed to
bring comic book movies to like a new
level you know take him seriously and be
even darker and more adult but still
sort of being a comic book movie uh so
really really like the second one like I
love Dark Knight uh and then we have the
Dark Knight Rises I didn't like this one
I thought this actually camp sucked and
I have no idea if I'm a minority on that
or if that's gonna be the popular view I
have no idea I haven't looked up and
seen what other people thought yet but I
got back from the midnight screening and
I was really underwhelmed by it I was
actually kind of shocked um there's two
things that I really really liked in it
uh one is Catwoman Catwoman is a great
half awaits
they're fine uh I think there could have
been a better actress possibly but she
does fine she's having fun she goes back
and forth between being like you know
the damsel screaming and then you know
going to Sirius mo and you know it's
like that was just for show I mean
playing the different parts and the
different characters and she's having
fun with it she's more of a spy in this
one and I love the Michelle Pfeiffer one
okay that's a great character an awesome
character but tonight
to see one more sort of like the comics
Oh love Catwoman lots of fun when you
see her in Batman together you know
whatever just walking down the street or
kicking ass it's awesome I mean so it's
and the stuff with the mask of the
goggles sort of looking like the ears so
you can understand why some people would
call her like the cat or the capper
where did she steal stuff
it was far as that you kind of clever so
love that stuff
second thing that was awesome paint
Bane's pretty cool I didn't think he
would be but they actually make him
really enjoyable and just how much he's
really soaking up and having it having
fun just being this villain not
everything you tried to throw at him I
mean just like oh you'll try to fight me
a guard well I was born in dark hello I
see you pow uh you know and he's very
intimidating as well and end his voice
whenever they give him some sort of
filter or something so you can hear it
better end even though he shoots I like
this these zones are one place like his
voice really projects somehow uh so for
that's what ever comic-book stuff uh
aside from that what really sort of
shocked me about this movie is that I
could really I couldn't give a crap what
was gonna happen the last you know like
half hour or whatever of the climax the
city fighting everyone's running in the
back plane is flying tanks explosions I
was looking at my watch I was so bored
by this and I think the reason for that
is uh one they don't make the main
character they don't make Batman that
interesting and this they don't have him
go through a much of a dilemma the other
films did this one I mean maybe he is
but they don't focus on it that much at
least not as much as they probably
should not not enough to get us you know
sort of like wow I feel what he's going
through you know we're going with him
through this journey so that's a problem
- biggest problem is the motivation for
the villains uh this is pretty much the
first film again the exact same plan
except it made even less sense it makes
even less sense in this one then it did
in the first one but the first one was a
Gotham is a a decaying City it's a
you know it's horrible it's like a you
know a diseased arm that needs to be
lopped off so the rest of civilization
can you know live okay
you know it's I guess I'll buy it you
know it sounds a little goofy but
whatever we'll we'll go with it okay uh
and then in this one it's like Gotham is
now a peaceful place because all that
bullshit at the end of the Dark Knight
you know with we have to make Batman
look like the villain and whatever and
Michael came burning the letter and
stuff like that all of that just got rid
of crime you know it's the streets are
safe they're gonna get rid of Jim Gordon
because this is peacetime by the way
that goes no way there is no reason for
that uh
so now Gotham's I guess a really pretty
nice place people want a vacation there
or something uh but these bad guys the
exact same ones the League of Shadows
come in and they still want to stomp it
out why because we got a plan we still
got the blueprints we got what we gotta
throw them away I mean we can't do that
it doesn't add up and that's the big
problem is that you're following these
villains and you're trying to get into
their plan uh
and when you get to the big battle at
the end the big everyone's rushing and
fighting you're constantly asking
yourself what the hell are they fighting
for what was this for again I am NOT
behind this even something like Avengers
you know is there a basic asshole wants
to take over the world I mean we know
that we've seen a million times what we
can get it we're still not sure exactly
what this is and there's a bomb that
they have that they could just blow up
in a moment in fact we find out that
they aren't just going to blow it up
they're holding the city hostage unless
they don't heed to their demands because
there's no demands they have to heat to
so they you know but what's the point
well they want to see the soul of Gotham
be crushed why to prove a point
the point that if we let a bunch of
prisoners out of their cells the city
will be in chaos I don't think you need
to prove that I think we could figure
that out and if no law enforcement is
there to
save on the city will crumble and die
yeah yeah uh you know and but we're
gonna blow it up anyway this is the
dumbest plan it doesn't add up and we
don't exactly know why they're doing it
it's just sort of stubbornness uh that's
one that's one of the many major
problems I mean I spread go a little bit
into the into the story here um you know
it's a few years later after dark and I
Bruce Wayne is now like a cripple which
did I miss something in the last one
like he has a cane and he can you know
just barely walk it when did that happen
Batman was walking okay at the end of
the first moment he could ride the bike
you know so but he decides to you know
secluded himself and get away from
everything because the death of Harvey
Dent was too much you know the death of
his parents as a kid you know that yeah
that that was tougher than this guy who
was nice man he turned out to be a jerk
I walk him some away from everything
he's like Howard Hughes he's got the you
know the long beard isn't uh so that
didn't make a whole lot of sense uh but
he decides to come back because the
Selina Kyle you know takes his
fingerprints uh uh you know Kay she's a
cat burglar in this you know sort of
playing both sides uh having a lot of
fun with it and so he wants to find out
why they find out about this Bane
character and Bane is apparently
connected to the League of Shadows I
don't think I'm giving anything away
they they say that pretty early on and
they just let us say he what's his plan
he wants to keep doing what Ra's al
Ghul's started now here isn't the other
major problem because that's essentially
the story and that's what uh you know
the Bane wants to do he just wants to
finish what Ra's al Ghul's started and
can when the sword goes back and forth
actually show that's what's so great
about that character uh what the reason
it doesn't work is that then what is the
purpose of the second movie what is the
purpose of the Joker what's even the
purpose of tufa you could easily write
these two things out
and just have uh what's the purpose of
framing a Batman for uh for the crime
write that stuff out okay go from Batman
Begins take out the Joker all that stuff
I'm done man I'm in the city I'm gonna
make it great go to this movie
everything's great because of Batman
well the bane doesn't want that if you
want revenge for Ra's al Ghul and
continue the rest of the story you don't
need the second film it's totally
pointless the Joker's totally pointless
two phases pretty much pointless and
almost decisions they decide to do at
the end you know with the I thought were
kind of bullshit anyway with Michael
game burning the letter and uh and
Batman taking the blame and Gordon going
along with n stuff really bites them in
the ass and everybody saying why the
hell did you do this this was stupid and
they're totally right I mean it's like
it just shot itself in the fun with his
own logic cuz everything they did in
that film is ultimately coming back and
everybody's yelling at them saying this
was the wrong thing to do and it was the
wrong thing to do it was a dumb dumb
idea so you have that going but the
trying to bring it back to the villains
in the first film uh it doesn't add up
because then they're trying to make it
look like this was all part of a plan
this was all part of the trilogy when
clearly it wasn't you know maybe you
were gonna do something with Heath
Ledger that was gonna bring it back into
this I don't know but as is you have
Batman Begins which is its own sort of
thing The Dark Knight which is kind of
continuing it but it's it's a little
thing Dark Knight Returns just listen to
the friggin title you're recycling the
title you know I mean Batman Begins two
Dark Knight two Dark Knight Returns it's
not much variation there um did you
learn anything from watching the Rambo
movies anyway uh so okay you have a Dark
Knight Rises and we're just gonna sort
of go back to what the first film was
doing we're gonna bring it back to that
whoa
this whole area with the Joker and
Toobin were you were really raising the
bar remember you were trying something
different and new and Wow
and why are you stepping backwards why
are you going in this direction and what
really bothers me is that from Batman
Begins The Dark Knight whether or not he
did you got the feeling that Christopher
Nolan was sort of taking notes at what
didn't work and Batman Begins like the
action scenes got so much better in dark
right uh whatever this villain got much
more focused in the Dark Knight uh you
know a lot of problems you know I like
Batman Begins a lot of the problems with
Batman Begins were fixed in Dark Knight
you know we think stuff you have a few
uh and then you get to Dark Knight Rises
and it's like he didn't maybe cuz
everyone did praise it so much but there
were so problems with the Dark Knight
and one of them is that goddamn voice
and I swear to god he's doing it on
purpose now he's making it sillier this
is the and I okay I don't blame Bale for
this I really don't because Christopher
Nolan is watching this and even if he
doesn't see it on sex I understand that
the ear I understand that in editing do
something to that voice dub it uh give
it more bass do Sonia fix Bane's voice
that sounded great it didn't make a
whole lot of sense it's unrealistic but
it sounded great why couldn't you do it
with Christian but everyone's made fun
of his voice I mean it's the funniest
goddamn thing in this movie he's just
he's sounding like he swallowed Donald
Duck or something you know I mean it's
like it can't do it you can't do it it's
too silly uh okay okay I'm sorry I just
and he talks so much in this and even
half the people know who he is are you
still doing this dumb as voice ha all
right so that that was really
distracting um in prometheus
that's weird be going to prometheus but
be versing the red letter media video
that they did for that where it's two
guys they're just sitting down there
just you know the couch one guy turns a
just asks every question you know about
a plot point or a hole that didn't make
sense in prometheus it goes on for like
three minutes cuz there's so many that's
this one and let me tell it's a comic
book movie I got that you know I'm the
guy who didn't really question in the
Dark Knight went like you know how did
the clowns during the big chase scene
know where the helicopters were gonna go
to set up those cords or know there's
gonna be
I'll capture and stuff it's like I
really I don't question that stuff
Edward Scissorhands I don't question ray
gets the big block of ice I'm cool with
it you know but there are so many damn
things in this movie or I'm like what
Han what what uh for example when they
capture Catwoman they put her in the you
know the male prison center what and I'm
sure they give a bullshit reason but you
know everyone saying the same thing
that's a bullshit reason uh they put
Bruce Wayne in this prison for a bit uh
and he has to find out a way out which
by the way the way he finds the way out
is extremely underwhelming it's supposed
to be like the big build above the movie
the title of the movie comes from this
and it's like one sentence and it's not
that big a development or at least you
don't see him go through a big
development you know he just tries
something I know that worked uh but okay
so I guess how this prison there's no
fucking guards there there's no guards
to make sure this guy who you frickin
know is Batman is gonna get out is that
what all one's ever got out of here
except for that one person that we
constantly reference all the time but
it's with attention at one person who is
very small a child actually but we're
pretty sure no one else is ever gonna
get at it and no one will ever figure
out the psychological secret or whatever
they claim it's a psychological secret
uh he gets out apparently this was in
like India or something like that makes
his way back to Gotham like just on the
street you don't know how and you got
nobody can get on this goddamn Island
now because they closed off all the
bridges army and military he gets on in
like two seconds he flies from India
gets back to this island that has
military all over the place and
terrorists all over the place and he
gets back fine I'm he's just like in the
corner late he sees where you go hey
what's up I mean it's there's a lot of
that there's a lot of these things that
distractingly don't add up and for films
that try so hard to show how all this
technical stuff happens like okay for
example the opening which I'm sure a lot
of us see and we're paying escapes with
the plane now that's mostly BS but we
can buy it because it is very
let's need a your sourcing how it's done
and you're giving us some idea but all
this other stuff all these other things
that they're doing that you just think
logically this would make sense or they
would try this or do this and they don't
or they don't explain it and it's so
weird because of that but oh what else
what else yeah those are the major
things um oh ok at the end that there's
a relatively good twist at the end I
mean it's one of those nice ones work it
was in plain sight the whole time you
just go oh ok don't see that comment ok
ah but again when you see what it's
adding up to and you sort of see oh this
is our villain you know this is the
villain you just go really Batman Batman
okay Batman movie this is your villain
this is what it's all coming down to you
have created the some of the world's
greatest villains I mean unbelieva these
characters right themselves they're so
unbelievable I mean and people have
prayed to write for Batman because they
want to write for these villains they're
that good and you have it boiled down to
this this person who clearly you don't
give a shit about I mean at all so
that's a problem there the ending I
can't believe this is how they're
finishing this movie again I won't give
it away but the ending to this movie is
not how a Batman film would end it's
more like how Shrek doing a Batman film
would end like oh isn't that kind of
cute oh isn't that kind of of the always
indie I don't know no no no this from
like from the point where Bruce Wayne
gets thrown in this prison on it doesn't
feel like Batman at all I'm not sure
what it feels like I don't know if it's
tried to do an Avengers thing where
they're just flying around the city and
they're trying to make it huge uh which
I feel bad saying because it looks like
a lot of time a lot of money a lot ever
went into this and a lot of stuff is
really there and a lot of the big crowds
and a lot of fighting and it's very
impressive but it just
give a shit you don't give a shit about
what happens to the city or Batman or
what the bad guys plan is and you're
just consul again you're constantly
asking why does why should I care about
this why should I care about the bad
guys plan about it Batman saves them or
any of this because it just seems like
it's what we've done in the first film
it just stretched out longer and made
bigger you know at least with the second
film they're going to serve this anarchy
and you don't want the Joker to win cuz
you want to believe in the best of
mankind but you know where the Joker's
coming from and you can sort of
understand it uh even though you don't
agree with her maybe you do even uh you
don't want to be on his side but it's
very challenging not to because you are
sort of agreeing with some of what he's
saying so that's great and even the
weird plan in the first Batman in Batman
Begins uh it kind of makes sense like
you don't agree with if you're like well
okay I guess that now you can almost
work in here it just doesn't add up it
just seems like stubborn dicks that
somehow got this really big budget and
all these henchmen and stuff and yet
they stove up with guards at that prison
um so and yeah like I said another big
issue with it is that you don't really
feel the hero's journey on this you
don't feel what he has to go through to
you know achieve this greatness and that
chabot district douchey posture my pot
or whatever it's called uh you know is
played throughout the whole thing it
means rise rise rise so they're really
building up this thing where the Dark
Knight Rises he he you know comes back
again stuff like that first of all he
comes back pretty quickly you know that
they're making it like you know he he's
gone for you know like halfway through
the movie he comes back and everyone's
gonna cheer he comes back pretty pretty
fast I mean nothing really snapped you
know it's like oh I guess I should
probably put the bad suit back uh yeah
yeah I'll do it out there I got
go um so I mean even that sort of
underwhelming um what else what else it
there's so many I mean this is one of
those things where I could just go
through the movie and just do like
bullet points like what I don't like
about it and what doesn't work for me um
so I guess maybe I'm a little harsh just
you know saying like oh it's like I
don't think it sucks I mean because
there's some good stuff in it but for
the direction these movies were going
and to take this direction and for us
not to be invested I never for me not to
be invested really kind of surprised me
uh and to keep doing the Batman voice
too and all that stuff so ok I'm not
trying to think there's anything else
that I really need to address oh ah and
this sort goes along with the ending -
okay so you have this uh this woman
who's kind uh sort of a financier it's
gonna take over Wayne Enterprises and
stuff like that and whatever she's she's
sort of you know against Wayne cuz he
becomes a recluse he's not keeping track
of its money which again you saw her go
yeah what a dick yo yeah he's the money
stuffing that keeping track of me these
leave me when you love um okay he gets
his act together and he tells her about
this machine that I guess he sort of
invented his spare time or you know
there's probably a story to it um you
know but it was just explained so fast
but can also be used as a weapon of
course as why he wants to keep it secret
uh so he sort of shows her this and you
know they're trying to get the company
back together and stuff like that and
then all of a sudden they're fucking
it's the hell happened there was no
chemistry at all it's like just suddenly
they're bonking each other it comes out
of nowhere uh you know it's like he used
that robot live from prometheus hey are
you a robot
oh do me you know it made no sense at
all
and then on top of that we don't really
know if him and the Catwoman are
supposed to be an item really I you know
certain near the end you surrogate Oh
are they I maybe they are
I don't know but again it's the final
film so this is what they're sticking
with
and at the very end I guess there's kind
of a clear answer but it's not one that
you were like yeah I see how they got to
that point um I think the only other
thing I'll talk about before I say
probably like everyone is uh it really
is sadly you know the sort of an example
of when there's too much story and not
enough character so I'm over got a camel
I was a good character Bane's good
character but like the first half hour
this movie is just exposition well what
happened here we'll listen this and that
and that well who's that well that's the
him and him and hurt her and blah blah
blah where's this going well that's
going to here and there in blah blah
blah I mean and a lot of its really
forced I mean just like you know just
shoving this shit in your face and just
talk talk talk talk talk tell we're
doing that we're doing that we're doing
this oh we're doing it that's that
person that's this person what's this
thing well this is that and it's it does
not flow its you're constantly where
your hearing exposition and they're not
introducing much character again with
the exception of Bane and Catwoman um
and that sort of follows it through and
like I said when you get to the heroes
quote-unquote journey in the middle in
the prison you don't feel like he's
going through hell you don't feel like
he's really you know that he's risen he
is you know he's rise rise you know as
they keep chanting by the way they chant
this thing about a million times a day
only unlike whatever day ten does he ask
what does that mean really you never
people on the internet are like what
does it be what does it mean you know
leaving when they saw the trailer they
saw for like the first min and they're
like what does that mean you waited ten
days to ask what what does that chanting
mean you know I'm like his fifth attempt
trying to get up this thing and I'm nipa
can't I act Ralphie it's nitpicking but
I'm going out of order here uh so it
really is one of those films were and
the Batman films actually a lot of
Christopher Nolan films I've always or
had that problem that there is much more
story than there is character is usually
enough character usually get like one
really really strong character yo the
Joe
her was that really really strong
character you know in Dark Knight or
actually of all baya Batman was back to
for a while oh really really strong
character in Batman Begins
so I usually sort carries it through
okay but in this one it's like it's just
overload and you're just tired of it and
you don't know you don't know why you're
supposed to be rooting for this or what
the big journey is or any of that um so
that that's frame that those are my
issues with the movie and there are some
good stuff there are some good effects
and I do like yeah woman I do like Bane
but everything else I just couldn't get
into it also
okay okay who would like this film my
guess is that people is gonna sound
weird and people who like from
Prometheus would like probably like a
film like this someone that wants
something really basic uh you know or
just want some basic action you might be
a little bored by that times because it
is extremely long uh but you can sort of
fall and you can follow it enough you
know again sort of almost near the the
third act there's a lot of how we can
get the cops out what we're gonna do
this why are we gonna do this we're
gonna do that more that exposition stop
that you're just um but and I think
people who you know are getting
themselves hiked up to see this and just
they want to seek out what they want to
see Bane they want to see people
punching people on explosions and stuff
and that sort of all they need they
don't need too much else uh cuz it's not
like there's nothing to this movie you
know they give little drops of you know
something to kind of cling on to for me
it's not up but if you only need a
little if you just want your basic
action movie it's not bad you might get
a little bored by it
at times but but you'll probably like it
okay um people who won't like it anyone
that really thinks this is gonna be love
big Batman that you know you want to see
it move on to the next level you want to
see the characters next development you
want to see all this stuff you're
probably gonna be underwhelmed by it I
don't know if you'll hate it
well you know I got because
is still some good things in it so I
don't think you'll say it sucks or
anything but you'll probably be let down
a bit especially after something like
Avengers that did so well at balancing
characters and this one you know Batman
sir disappears for a while Bane's or
disappears for a while you know stuff um
and it's just so hard to get into the
main character's dilemmas I guess um so
yeah hopefully that gives you some idea
of it personally if I had to guess I
mean I I don't know a fan react and me
love it it give people applaud it at the
end um I really don't know if people are
gonna be like Dawg you're fucking
asshole for this or people are gonna be
like yeah dude that's that's what I
thought
so I really don't know I don't know how
people are going to accept this film um
my guess would be that in terms of
what's gonna be the big money maker at
Dark Knight Rises might have the bigger
opening weekend possibly but I think
Avengers is the safe bet for the one
that would have people coming back I
don't know how many people would come
back to this that's what I find so
intricate it is so long and there is
just so much talking explaining
exposition and there's not something you
really get behind Avengers again is very
simple and just stuck to it you know it
has a lot of complicated things going on
but we get down to it's a very basic
story and people like that
um and it's good action so yeah that
that's pretty much my two cents about it
uh I could possibly be a little too
harsh on it maybe you know cuz like I
say it looks like people worked really
hard on it and it's not without any
character there's some good stuff but
yeah it did not do anything for me and
I'm a Batman fan I liked Dark Knight and
I liked Batman Begins but this did not
do it for me and I really don't think
it's a satisfactory ending by any means
really um in fact it's almost like I say
it's almost like a joke ending or a
dumbell ending you know like wow what I
go oh you're way too much um but uh yeah
so just personally not a
and if you like it great and just didn't
do anything for me so that's about it
guys and I'll talk to you later